the Saints try to do anything they can
to motivate themselves Chris no matter
how good you are you always try to find
something to get yourself motivated and
even if it's stealing the thing that
another team is using to motivate itself
that's what happens it worked for the
Saints even though it looked like it
wasn't going to down 14 to nothing and
there was a sequence there late in the
first quarter into the second quarter
where it could have gone either way for
the Saints the scoop and score attempt
by the Eagles defense that failed the
interception that was thrown by Nick
Foles on the third snap of the second
quarter right Marshall Adam Moore with
his first pick and then when the Saints
driving down the field fourth and short
the fake punt that Taysom Hill firing
the team up just like he did in Tampa
when he blocked a punt that tastes him
he'll moment was the thing that I think
really caused the Saints to snap out of
their funk and score the first touchdown
and methodically take down the Eagles
and and slam the door on them note
points the final three quarters for
Philadelphia I mean it was done it was
really domination from that point on I
mean it really it was changed the
football game Latimore's interception of
course was huge because the the Eagles
were getting close to you know fringe
field goal territory and you're saying
oh no I they gonna go up 17th and
nothing or 21 and nothing and the Saints
would have been in deep trouble but as
you saw in that clip there not only was
it the fake punt and great play call by
Sean Payton to you know change the flow
with a football game where momentum was
totally on the ego side but Fletcher Cox
the best player in the game okay got
hurt Fletcher Cox on that fake punt hurt
his knee missed a significant amount of
time not only in the rest of the first
half there but was in and out of the
lineup in the second half as well and
really from that point on that's where
time of possession just got out of hand
right guys I mean what was it at the end
of the day the Saints had the ball for
37 minutes and 50 seconds and the Eagles
had the ball for 22 minutes and 10
seconds and that's after the Eagles
having it what in the first quarter
stats about 10 minutes of the time 12
minutes of the time 9 minutes and 48
seconds in the first quarter for Philly
just twelve plus minutes the rest of the
game that's unbelievable and I think
that just alone shows you that they
dominated the line of scrimmage
about that point on and on both sides of
the ball and I got to give Sean Payton
Sean Payton has this uncanny ability
first of all he's got guts I mean he
just got no fear but this uncanny
ability to know okay my team doesn't got
it right now I'm gonna have to be the
spark and it's very rare that the coach
can do that but whether it's an onside
kick to beat the Colts so to start the
second half of the Super Bowl or plays
like this that we have seen him do all
year long this is why Sean Payton is
really one of the greatest coaches of
our era because his ability to make his
team stuff of course his offensive
genius but knowing when to kind of
interject himself into the game to
change it and I get to give him a lot of
credit like I said because he's an
amazing and that was a gutsy call yeah
and and you're absolutely right they
needed something to wake up and that did
it and Thomas Moore stead there's an
item on pft that Maurstad says he was
lobbying Payton to go for it but it
sounds like Payton was going for it
anyway because that that's just what
they do we have seen this now and it to
the point where it irritates some people
that coaches are so aggressive
they're just recklessly aggressive hey
we're aggressive hey I'm trying to win
the game well yeah we're trying to win
the game but try not to lose the game
while you're at trying to win the game
but Payton has a good sense of timing as
to when the right time is to go for it
when you should call the fake punt when
you should have a surprise onside kick
in Super Bowl 44 I mean that's one of
the all-time gutsiest move year for
years before coaches were being
aggressive that arguably helped deliver
the only Super Bowl championship the
Saints have ever won and they may be on
the verge of getting to number two it
and if you're if you are a Falcons fan
right now you are dreading what could
happen on Sunday right because the
Saints are going to punch their ticket
to come to your building right to come
to the the brand new mercedes-benz dome
and if the Saints win a Super Bowl yeah
in your house yeah whoo dad just rebuilt
the Georgia Dome and tear that place
down it's got bad karma
they get rid of it yeah I hear you
they're not gonna want to hear about
that all week of the Falcons players
they might want to move out of town or
go on vacation if the Saints do go to
the Superbowl because yes that will as a
division rival certainly make you angry
to go oh my gosh we got to hear about
this team in our city playing their
biggest game of the year in our stadium
will absolutely drive you crazy
certainly but you know I think you know
back to the game just one point I'd like
to make Mike I mean yes we talked about
you know the momentum the injuries that
the Philadelphia Eagles had to overcome
not only in this game of the season I
think all came back to bite them you
know Brandon Brooks went down yesterday
Fletcher Cox we talked about getting
banged up Michael Bennett but then their
inability to play man-to-man on the back
end a few times because Ronald Darby was
hurt for the year Rasul Douglas got hurt
in the game yesterday and I think that's
why you saw Michael Thomas start to free
up in the middle of the field and really
gash them for some big games Michael
Thomas was incredibly unstoppable and
I'm surprised the Saints only scored 20
points if you told me before the game
the Saints only scored 20 I figured
they'd lose they win
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports